joining me now is rob o'neal retired
navy seal team six operator
and jeremy hunt west point grad and army
vet
rob uh what is this push to purge
all about tonight laura yeah the push to
purge is what it always is is they're
trying to politicize anything they can
to hurt the right everything from using
the national guard and bringing in some
20-plus thousand troops and surrounding
the capital with
fences i mean if you won 80-plus million
votes why do you need to protect it
plus you know we didn't we're not there
to be politicized as military we're
there to to support and defend
democracy and they write the rules for
us
um they politicize us these are the
people that jump behind their desks when
the demons come
we're the ones that kill the demons and
all they're doing is using us
and it's you mentioned morale earlier
morale is very very important for these
men and women to do their job which is
very hard and underpaid
and stuff like this is just you lose
morale they are all there to fight for
this country i served under
president clinton president bush
president obama and i know uh president
trump i've met president biden i i was
there to serve
the country not because i'm a republican
or democrat because i'm an american
jeremy when you look at the capital
i find it incredibly depressing we found
out today
that uh in this homeland security
committee hearing that experts are
saying oh
this could be 10 to 20 years
of a domestic extremist threat that
requires fortification of the capital
and meanwhile our southern border is
open what are your thoughts on this
i mean i'm telling you right now when
the when the left
looks at the government and looks at
levers of the government looks at
even nonpartisan institutions like the
military they see them as
tools uh to use as political props to
use as tools to enact their vision
and even with this with the order uh
that secretary austin uh
uh came out with today you know i hope
this is not another iteration of the
the biden bait and switch where he says
hey we're going to target white
supremacy and racism
uh where many of us everyday americans
say that's wonderful yeah let's
let's target uh extremism uh but then he
switches it up and says well actually
what i mean when i say white supremacy i
mean
if you think differently than the way we
want you to think
if you're a conservative if you're a
libertarian some of my libertarian
friends are now under fire
um if you are a christian as you
mentioned earlier uh all of these things
are now grounds
uh to say that you are a white
supremacist or a racist and so i hope
that's not the direction secretary
austin is going with us
um he's an honorable man he's served
honorably he's a lot of respect across
the aisle
um but it's it's it's really unsettling
and here's another part that i hope
people understand is that with these
stand down orders what often happens is
that there's a training accompanied with
it
and what happens is they'll train you on
in this case it might be
diversity training or eo equal
opportunity training and the question is
well
what's going to be a part of the
curriculum is it going to be the the
critical race theory trash that says
that
all white people are evil or is it going
to be truth it says we're all god's
children created in his images and we're
all
uh born equal uh so you know that's the
question and so right now
we have to do our job as americans and
put pressure on the pentagon
uh to to defend the people who have been
defending us for generations
yeah i just don't want to yeah i'm sorry
sorry to interrupt jeremy but rob i
don't want to spend a single u.s
taxpayer dollar on
blm style curricula for the u.s military
which last time i checked none of you
cared what color
one person is to the next if you guys
are working together or
women working together in in a military
operation whether you're
a mechanic or whether you're a forward
operator
right before the one of the first things
they do when we get to uh
boot camp or basic training it doesn't
matter where we're from or what we look
like
we we get our head shaved we put on the
same clothes because it's called being
in uniform
and they're going to break us down and
realize we are one team and we're one
fight
and even when we got over there when
even when i was a seal team six i didn't
care what they did behind closed doors i
didn't care who was gay or straight what
i cared about
can you do the job if i get hit can you
carry me and all my gear
home that's it there are two things in
combat you either win
or you die and i need people there men
and women that are there to fight
that's it but the the phrase
domestic terrorist jeremy in reference
to the u.s military i think
all i just know so many wonderful
veterans and active duty but i
have a lot of veteran friends young guys
like rob all you guys a young guy
and the the the sacrifice the hard work
what's happened to families back home
who don't get enough credit for what
they do
how many horrible injuries and now
this is what they get they're
immediately suspicious
if they're if they voted for a
republican or if they went to a rally
and stood there it's insanity
it really is i mean i remember when i
was serving we had people who were
there were leftists we had liberals we
had libertarians conservatives and
i remember even in 2016 we had some
spirited debates about you know the
future of our country and what that
meant
but at the end of the day we all packed
up our stuff completed the mission
and we're still one team and that that's
the spirit of the military and that's
what we stand to lose
if we let the left use the army and
other service branches
as some type of political prop as just
another uh
weapon and their and their war and their
cultural war
so it's very important that now is the
time that we speak up
we will not be silenced uh and it's time
that we start uh helping those who have
helped us for so long
well warriors not social justice
warriors other people want to do that
they can't you guys are
you guys were warriors thank you so much
gentlemen both both